new zealand has chosen the first
transgender athlete to compete at its
olympic games
laurel hubbard is a female weightlifter
who will be in tokyo next month
supporters call her selection a
breakthrough for transgender's community
for the transgender community it's also
reignited a debate with critics who say
it's unfair for an athlete who used to
compete with men
to participate in women's sports mts
taya
has the story
for the headline making and
barrier-breaking weight lifter
all she wants to do is compete i
am who i am i'm not here to change the
world
i just want to you know be me
and just do what i do
43 year old laurel hubbard who
transitioned from male to female in 2012
is considered a serious metal contender
after being selected to represent her
home country new zealand
at the tokyo games she is a very
dedicated and resilient athlete and on
behalf of laura
i would like to say how honoured she is
to be in the team
hubbard also has the backing of the
international olympic committee
the governing body introduced
transgender guidelines for athletes
back in 2015. under the rules those who
transition from male to female
can compete in the women's category as
long as their testosterone was kept
below a certain level for at least a
year
joanna harper a medical physicist and
competitive runner
who was also trans helped advise the ioc
on its guidelines pre-transition and
post-transition
did that change your ability to be a
competitive athlete
when i transitioned within
nine months of hormone therapy i was
running 12 percent slower that's the
difference between serious male athletes
and serious female athletes
is it fair the absolute answer to that
question
is still not certain we need a lot more
data
before we can come to an absolute
conclusion on that
for those opposed to hubbard's inclusion
in the games her competitive advantage
over other women is certain
males do have a performance advantage
that's based on their biological sex
they outperform us on every single
metric speed
stamina strength picking testosterone is
a red hearing i mean we're forgetting
about
the anatomy the fast-twitch muscle the
bigger
organs for hubbard's supporters whether
she wins gold
or not being allowed to compete at the
olympics
as a woman against other women is
already a victory
for trans rights
for cbs this morning london
it's a really naughty problem for the
very naughty president and as we heard
there the absolute
question of of is it fair still really
hasn't been answered
yet and yet onward it goes yeah and if
she meddles i can imagine another woman
being on the medal stand wondering
would i be winning gold or bronze or
if she weren't here so um it's very
complicated stuff